[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جامبو في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من رام الله وتصعيد للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في انحاء مختلفه من الضفه
الغربيه احداثه في نابلس
الى العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس التي وصل
اليها اليوم ويليامبرز في اول زياره منذ
توليه منصب مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه
والى واشنطن تحديدا البيت الابيض عشيه قمه
مرتقبه تجمع الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس
الوزراء الياباني
الذي يقوم حاليا بجوله اوروبيه امريكيه
شمال
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في موجه تصعيد جديد في الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال تقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين
وتصيبوا العشرات في عمليات اقتحام بجنين
ونابلس وقلنديا وتشن حمله دم واعتقال في
مناطق اخرى ويكيدام اون لاينز والامين
العام للامم المتحده يقول ان الياس والغضب
يتفاقمان بسبب سياسه هدم المنازل
والاستيطان الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
قائد القوات البريه الروسيه في بيلاروسيا
بعد ساعات من تعيينه نائبا لقائد العمليات
في اوكرانيا موسكو تقول ان الزياره لتفقد
القوات المشتركه للبلدين قبل مناورات
الجويه ومن الجانب المقابل من الحدود رئيس
الاركان الاوكرانيه يعلن عن تعزيزات
دفاعيه تحسبا لاي طارق
وقياده قوته الجويه تحذر من نشر اسلحه
تكتيكيه روسيه على الاراضي البلاسيه
مديره وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
في ليبيا في ارفع زياره لمسؤول من اداره
بيض
بنز يجتمعوا مع رئيس حكومه الوحده في
طرابلس قبل توجه الى بنغازي للقاء حفتر
العلاقات الثنائيه
الروسيه تتصدر الاجنده
قبل وصول رئيس الوزراء الياباني الى
الولايات المتحده واشنطن وتوكيو تعلناني
توسيعه حالتهما الدفاعيه بما فيه الردع
النووي وتؤكدان ان الصين تشكل اكبر تحدي
الاستراتيجي للبلدين
وبجين تدعوهما لعدم الاضرار بمصالح اي طرف
اخر من خلال تعاونهم العسكري
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سياقه زيارتي ويليام بنز
الاولى
للعاصمه الليبيه طرابلس منذ توليه منصب
مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
ومحدثاتها مع رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
عبد الحميد الطبيبه
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد فرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم في اي سياق تاتي
زياره مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه للعاصمه الليبيه الاجابه جاءت
على النحو التاليه نحو 67% قالوا ناس
زياره تاتي في سياق وساطه امريكيه لحل
الازمه الليبيه في حين قال نحو سته في
المئه فقط ان هدف زياره هو دعم المبعوث
الاممي الاردني
على خلفيه قضايا امنيه بين واشنطن وطرف
هذا سؤال سيخبط روحا على من اساطير
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا وان نتطررق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
وزير العدل الامريكي يعلن تعيين مستشار
خاص لتحقيق في العثور على وثائق سريه داخل
منزل بيضه
[موسيقى]
تصعيد جديد في الضفه الغربيه
حيث قتل قوات الاحتلال ثلاثه فلسطينيين في
اقتحامه
قتل قوه خاصه من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
فلسطينيين اثنين
مصادر للجزيره بان القوات الخاصه حصلت
منزلين داخل بلده قباطيه بذريعه ملاحقه
مطلوبين لاسرائيل بتهمه التخطيط لتنفيذ
عمليه مسلحه ضدها
وفي مخيم قلنديا الشماليه القدس تم تشييع
جثمان شهيد سمير اصلا الذي قتلته قوه
الاحتلال خلال عمليه اعتقال نجله واعلن
الجيش الاحتلال ان قوته تعرضت لاطلاق نار
من مسلحين فلسطينيين خلال عمليه اعتقال
احد كوادر مجموعتي عرين الاسود كما شلت
قوه الاحتلال حمله اعتقالات واسعه في
انحاء الضفه وقد افاد نادي الاسير
باعتقاله 24 فلسطينيه خلال ساعات الاربع
والعشرين الماضي
في مخيمي قلنديا للاجئين شمال القدس اوقفت
قوات الاحتلال 16 فلسطينيه وقتلت سميره
اصلا وهو اب
لثمانيه ابناء كان يحاول الوصول الى نجله
رمزي الذي اعتقلته القوات الاحتلال حين
اطلق جندي رصاصه مباشره عليه وترك ينسف
حتى الموت يعني لو كان في مقاومه او كان
في ضرب حجار او اي شيء كل واحد بيحكي بس
يعني اخوي اللهم انه بس ظل عن السطح طخه
بدم بارد ولكنه طخ بني ادم
في هذه الاثناء كانت قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
البلده القديمه في نابلس حاصرت حاره
الياسمين والمحاور الرئيسيه
وقبل الانسحابها اصابت سبعه فلسطينيين
بالرصاص واعتقلت مقاومه من عرين الاسود و
اربعه من رفاقه
وبعد انتهاء العمليه العسكريه لملمت
الامهات الشراح
الشعب الفلسطيني الذي يبقي مكتوب الايدي
لديه جميع الخيارات مفتوحه من اجل الدفاع
عن نفسه على المجتمع الدولي والاداره
الامريكيه التدخل السريع للجم تصرفات هذه
الحكومه
مع الاجراءات الانتقاميه السياسيه
والماليه الجديده
لكن في الفلسطينيه يخشون ان يكون هذا
العام اكثر دمويه كون الحكومه الجديده تضم
احزاب توصف بالاكثر تطرفا واستهلت مهامها
بتدليس المقدسات
والاعتقالي والقتل وفي اثني عشر يوما
اقتحم الوزير لتمار بن كفير المسجد الاقصى
ودمر مستوطنون مقابر مسيحيه وقتل جنود
الاحتلال سبعه فلسطينيين واعتقلوا اكثر من
100 وسبعين فلسطينيه
في هذه الاثناء خلل من العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريشن الغضب والياس
يتزايدان بسبب توسيع اسرائيل للمستوطنات
وهدمها للمنازل وتنفيذها لعمليات الاخلاق
جاء ذلك خلال جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس الامن
الدولي بشان القانون الدولي اعرب فيها
جوتييرش عن قلقه البالغ اذا ما وصفه
بمبادرات احاديه وذلك في اشاره الى اقتحام
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيليه باحات
الاقصى
توينتي توينتي 2 كان عام 2022 عاما مميتا
لكل من الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين ندين
جميع اعمال القتل غير المشروع والاعمال
التي يرتكبها المتطرفون في الوقت نفسه
يؤدي توسيع المستوطنات من قبل اسرائيل
وهدم المنازل وعمليات الاخلاء الى اثاره
الغضب والياس كما انني اشعر بقلق ايذاء
المبادرات الاحاديه التي شهدناها في
الايام الاخيره
مرحبا بك همم دكتور محمود هل ما يجري في
الضفه الغربيه استمرار لنهج اسرائيلي قديم
ام فيه من ملامح الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده
عمليه ان هذا النهج الذي نراه الان
والتصعيد الذي تقوم به اسرائيل في معظم
انحاء الضفه الغربيه هو استمرار للسياسات
الاسرائيليه التي امتدت على العامل خطوط
طيضه العام الفائت خلال الحكومه لبيد ومن
ثم قبله الحكومه السابقه والان هذه
الحكومه تصعب اكثر في في خطواتها
وسياستها تجاه الضفه الغربيه وخاصه اتجاه
السلطه الفلسطينيه مع الضفه الغربيه يعني
هنا في تصعيد في مستويين ضد الشعب كشعب
فلسطيني وفي اماكن تواجده وكذلك ضد السلطه
الفلسطينيه كسلطه او كحكومه تحكم الشعب
ولذلك هنا السياسه الاسرائيليه همم يعني
تهدف عمليه في هذه الفتره الى ايصال الشعب
الفلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه وكذلك السلطه
الفلسطينيه الى الهاويه الى الحافه قبل
انهيار هل ستسمح لهذه السلطه ان تنهار ومن
ثم ينهار كل المنظومه السياسيه في الضفه
الغربيه هذا السؤال الكبير ولذلك ان ترى
انه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد
ارسال وزير الخارجيتها الى المنطقه الى
للتداول في هذه القضيه الوضع الذي تعيشه
الضفه الغربيه حقيقه ووضع خطير جدا وخاصه
انه الناس الشعب العادي في بيوتهم ليسوا
في ليسوا في امان من قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اسرائيل اسرائيل
نعم يعني اسرائيل تهدي في الان من خلال
هذا التصعيد الى همم يعني الى ان تنهار
السلطه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي الى انهاء
الشعب الفلسطيني طيب لو تحدثنا في المقابل
همم الى ما يمكن ان تؤدي هذه السياسه من
رد فعل فلسطيني وما هي مخاطرها فعلا
يعني الشعب الفلسطيني انا لا يعني كم
يستطيع ان يتحمل من سياسه القتل والهدم
والتجويع والتضييق عليه يعني واضح وضوح
تام انه هذه السياسه الكولونيليه
الاستعماريه المتواصله والتي لم تنقطع
خلال اكثر من العامين في الضفه الغربيه
ستؤدي الى ردود فعل كبيره جدا وقد يعني
واا متوقع انه هذه السياسه سيكون مردوده
في داخل العمق الاسرائيلي مثلما حصل قبل
حوالي عام ونصف يعني وهذا سيكون عمليه
تنفيذ عمليه للغضب الفلسطيني وللقاهر الذي
نراه امام اعيننا يوما بعد يوم يعني قتل
الناس مثلما رايتهم في التقرير الذي
قدمتموه بدمن بارد اعدام بارد دون اي يعني
سبب هؤلاء الناس سيؤدي في النهايه الى
موجه غضب نحن نشعر بها ونستشعرها في انحاء
ضفه الغربيه ولا بد انتقل الى الداخل
الاسرائيلي سيد محمود هنا ما مصلحه
اسرائيل باختصار ما مصلحه اسرائيل في
الضغط الى حق الى هذا المستوى والى هذا
الحد وايصال الشعب الفلسطيني الى الى
الحافه
واين مصلحتها في انهيار السلطه ايضا
المصلحه هي تركيبه الحكومه نفسها لدينا
تركيبه حكومه من مستوطنين يعني وزراء في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه نفسهم مستوطنون
وهؤلاء يؤمنون ايمانا كاملا بانه لا يجوز
شيئا اسمه فلسطين ولذلك انت ترى في
الوثائق الرسميه منذ اقامه هذه الحكومه
تنازلوا عن كلمه الضفه الغربيه واصبح حتى
في يعني المصطلحات الرسميه يستعملوا كلمه
ارض اسرائيل ويهوده وهذا الاستعمال لهذا
المصطلحات ليس صدفه انما هو يعبر عن الخطه
الكولونياليه الكامله التي تسعى في
النهايه الى يعني ايجاد الوقت المناسب او
الساعه المناسبه من اجل الاعلان عن ضم
المناطق جيم في الضفه الغربيه الى اسرائيل
وابقاء السلطه الفلسطينيه السلطه على
منطقه صغيره جدا وهي المنطقه التي تعتبر
فقط المدن الفلسطينيه شكرا هذا هو المخطط
الذي تسعى اليه هذه القوه الجميميه في
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهذا واضح وضوح
تام شكرا لكم شكرا لكم محمود يزبك استاذ
دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه حيفا حدثنا
من النار
[موسيقى]
قل للمتحدث باسم قياده القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انه معظمنا الصواريخ البالسيه
الروسيه اطلقت من اراضي بيلاروسيا وان
القوات الاوكرانيه تعزز قدراتها الدفاعيه
على الحدود مع بلاروسيا تحسبا لاي تطورات
كانت وزاره الدفاع البلاء الروسيه قد قالت
ان اللجنه العسكريه روسيه بقياده قائد
القوات البريه
ساليو كوفا قد ذهبت الى روسيا وتفقدت
القوات المشتركه هناك قبل ايام من انطلاق
مناورات روسيه بلا روسيه تثير نخاوي كثير
يزور قائد القوات البريه الروسيه
بيلاروسيا على راس لجنه عسكريه الروسيه
يصل اليك سيلكوب الى بيلاروسيا بصفته
نائبا للقائد الجديد للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا تقول وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان اللجنه تفقدت الوحدات العسكريه
الروسيه ضمن القوات الاقليميه المشتركه في
ميادين التدريب ببيلاروسيا الزياره الاولى
للرجل بعد قرار موسكو تغيير قيادتها
العسكريه في الحرب قبل ايام قليله تم
تعيينه فاليري جرسيموف قائدا للقوات
الروسيه المشتركه في اوكرانيا يقول لك ان
تجديد القياده مرتبط بتوسيع نطاق مهام
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
الاهم في توقيت الزياره هو التدريبات
المشتركه المنتظره على الحدود الشماليه
الاوكرانيا ستعود مشاهد كهذه وتلك مناورات
القوه الروسيه والبيلاروسيه على الحدود
قبل ايام من اندلاع الحرب ستعود هذه
القوات بعد ايام قليله لتتدرب في الاجواء
البيلاروسيا
على الجانب الاخر من الحدود يجتمع الرئيس
الاوكراني بالمسؤولين العسكريين للبلاد
يترقبوا الجميع بحجر شديد مناورات الروس
مع البيلاروسين يتفقد قائد القوات
الاوكرانيه جنوده على الحدود مع بلاروسيا
لا يشكل الوضع الحالي على الحدود مع بلا
روسيا اي تهديد حتى الان لا مؤشرات على
عمليه بريه من الاعراض بلا روسيه ضد
اوكرانيا لكننا نتعامل بحذر ونراقب
باستمرار اي تطورات هناك نتصرف بهدوء انه
باحترافيه باستنادا الى المعلومات التي
نملكها ونزيد من التدريبات ونرفع قدراتنا
الدفاعيه هذا القلقله الاوكراني يتحول الى
مناورات على الارض تنهي التدريبات
الاوكرانيه في الجبهه الشماليه هدوء استمر
لشهور وتعيد الى الاذهان مشاهد الهجمات
الروسيه انطلاقا من الاراضي البيلاروسيا
لتلك الاراضي صوره قاتمه في اذهان
الاوكرانيين في فبراير الماضي كانت مناوره
الروسيه البيلاروسيه هناك مجرده تمهيد
للهجوم الروسيه معا اندلاع الحرب فتح
المجال الجوي البيلاروسيه امام الطيران
والصواريخ الروسيه نحو اوكرانيا بعد شهرين
من اندلاع الحرب انطلقت مناورات الروسيه
بلا روسيه جديده وبعد ثمانيه اشهر اتفق
الرئيسان الروسي والبلروسي على انشاء قوات
اقليميه مشتركه وهذه القوه التي ستجرى
مناوراتها بعد ايام وعدت الى العاصمه
البيلاروسيه اخر اسبوع من العالم الماضي
ما جدد المخاوف الاوكرانيه من دوري
بيلاروسيا في هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
القدير العسكري والاستراتيجي سيد بازل
مرحبا بك هل من دوري اضافيه
لروسيا في هذه الحرب دائما لروسيا ضد
اوكرانيا
اوبراير
لروسيا وهي توفر مساحه من فرصه من اراضيها
لقوات الروسيه لاطلاق صواريخ على اوكرانيا
وفي المراحل الاولى للحرب في فبراير وفي
مارس من السنه الماضيه فان القوات الروسيه
قامت باطلاق الغزو من بلا اراضي
البيلاروسيه لكن بلا روسيا نفسها لم تتخذ
دورا مباشر
همم
حجمه صغير وهنالك اربع او خمس
صناعه
بالجيش الكبير او بال- لديه عداد عسكري
كبير ولا يقارن بال الجيش الاوكراني مثلا
لكي تعود الى او تشترك في المعارك قد تحشد
ربما او التجند 300,000 احتياطي لكن مساله
لكن نظام همم القوي لو كان هو ليس حريصا
وليس متحمسا لقيام بهذا الامر لتفادي اي
ازمات للداخليه بلا روسيا ربما همم
ستستمر في المستقبل
ستكون على حافه هذا الصراع على جانب
الروسي لكنها لن تنخرط لن تتجاوزه هذا
الخط طيب انطلاقا من زياره قائد القوه
البريه الروسيه الى همم بلا روسيا هل همم
هل يمكن او
هل ما زال همم الهجوم البري من الاراضي
البيلاروسيه
مستبعدا طبعا هجوم بري روسي ولكن انطلاقا
من الاراضي البيلاروسيا هل الامر ما زال
مستبعدا
الرئيس
قوات الى بيلاروسيا لكنها ليست كبيره قال
لك شينكو انه كان هنالك تسعه الاف او ربما
10,000 جندي روسي مره اخرى هذا ليس بالحجم
الكبير لما تملكه اوكرانيا من العدد
والاسلحه بالتاكيد فان القوات الروسيه
والبيلاروسيا على
الاجزاء الشماليه والحدود الشماليه
لاوكرانيا هذا يعني ان اوكرانيا عليها ان
تبقى همم قوات احتياطيه هناك وهي تقوم
بذلك بالتالي هو نوع من التشتيت اللي همم
البادئ بعمليه عسكريه هذا الامر سيد يتطلب
قوات اكبر تتحرك في ذلك الاتجاه وايضا مره
اخرى فان بلا روسيا واوكرانيا يفصل لهما
همم
بحيرات وانهار ما تسمى بمناطق طاليسيا
والهي ليست ربما امم سهله في لكي يتم خوض
فيها معارك بالتالي المعركه ليست وشيك لكن
الاحتماليه نعم موجود لكنها بعيده
شكرا جزيلا لك
ومعنى من كياب نتاليا همنيوكا المتحدثه
باسمي قياده العمليات الجويه في الجيش
الاوكرانيه سيدنا نتالي مرحبا بك لماذا
همم تثير المناورات
البلا الروسيه الروسيه مخاوف
سيدنا داليا
لادريان
ان كانت سيده نتاليا تسمعنا على كل سنعود
اليها لمناقشه هذا الموضوع في طبيعه الحال
الغموض لا يزال يحيط بمصير المعارك
الدائره في مدينه سوليدار شرقي اوكرانيا
الروسيه الخاصه بان مقاتليها حاسم المعارك
على الارض الامر الذين مؤكده ان جنودها لا
يزالون ياخذون قتالا عنيفا هناك متيمه
موسكو بانها ترسل الالاف من الروس الى
الموت على امل تحقيق مبادره استراتيجيه في
سوريا
لا تزيد مساحتها كثيرا على اثني عشر كيلو
مترا مربعا لكنها اصبحت اليوم العنوان
الاهم في يوميات الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا الحديث هنا عن سوليدار المدينه
الصغيره الواقعه في الشمال الشرقي لمقاطعه
دونيت احياء وشوارع كانت وما تزال مسرحا
لمعارك طاحنا بين الجيش الاوكراني والقوات
الروسيه وتحديدا اكثر مقاتلي فاجنر الذين
اصبحوا بمثابه راس الحربه الذي تراهن عليه
موسكو على ما يبدو لتحقيق نصر على ارض
السوليدار وباي ثمن لا سيما في ظل
الانتكاسات الميدانيه التي تعرض لها الجيش
الروسي في الاشهر الاخيره ورغم اعلان
المجموعه الروسيه العسكريه الخاصه بان
قواتها احكمه السيطره على المدينه وبانها
قضت على كل من رفض الاستسلام فان اللافته
هنا دعوه الكرملين للت في قبل اعلان النصر
مع الاشاده بما وصفها بالاعمال البطوليه
لمقاتلي فاجنر على جبهات القتال في حين
سارعت قياده العمليات الاوكرانيه للتاكيد
على ان جنودها لا يزالون يخوضون قتالا
شرسا في سوليدار مع الاعتراف بان الوضع
صعب للغايه خصوصا ان تامين خطوط الامداد
بات امرا عسيرا فالجيش الاوكراني يدرك ان
المعركه هناك لا تتعلق فقط ممن يسيطر على
المدينه التي سوءت غالبيتها بالارض فهي
ايضا تعد بمثابه خط الدفاع الاخير
والبوابه الشماليه لمدينه باخموت التي
تحاول القوات الروسيه السيطره عليها منذ
الصيف لكنها فشلت لذلك حتى الان
رغم الهجمات الصاروخيه العنيفه والزنج
بمقاتل فاجنر على خطوط القتال الاماميه
قبل ان ترسلهم وسكو لاحقا الى جبهته
سليدار على امل ان يكون الحس هناك بمثابه
نقطه تحول لمسار الحرب المستمره منذ نحو
320 يوما
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نعودوا همم الى ضيفتنا من
كياف نتاليا هوميوك المتحدثه باسم قياده
العمليات الجنوبيه في الجيش الاوكراني
ولكن للحديث عما يجري على الحدود
الشماليه من اوكرانيا تحديدا المناورات
المرتقبه بين القوات الجويه الفلاروسيا
والروسيه اضافه الى تفقد قائد القوات
البريه
الروسيه
لقوته في بيلاروسيا هذه
المناورات تثير مخاوف همم على ما يبدو
ونسال ضيفتنا همم
ناتاليا من كيف عن سبب هذه
المخاوف اذا لماذا اخشى اوكرانيا تلك
المناورات البيلاروسيه الروسيه مع العلم
انها تستبعد اي هجوم روسي من الاراضي
البيلاروسيه حتى الان
اوكرانيا
تخشى هذه التدريبات اوكرانيا لم تخشى اي
تدريبات من الجانب
روسي ان اوكرانيا هي دوله تحاول ان تعيش
في عالم متحضر وهي تتعلم هذا بسرعه اما
همم التدريبات في الدوله
المجاوره الدوله الدوله همم ان هذه
التدريبات مساله تعود لهم انهم هم من
يحاول ان يخدعوا العالم كله
ويقوم بخداع العالم ويظهر ان هذه
التدريبات هي ليست تحضير للحرب انها تحضر
للحرب وليست تدريبات لذلك لا احد يصدقهم
الكل راى همم حقيقه ان نواياهم انهم
يحاولوا ان يمثلوا انها تدريبات ثم يقوم
بتدريب
الجنود ويفرضون على دول الاخرى همم ما
يريدونه هم وهذا لن ينجح معه اوكرانيا في
كل مره كانوا يقولوا للعالم ان هذه
تدريبات سلميه
كانوا يقوموا بعد هذا بتصرفات قذره
ونحن نعلم جيدا هذه القصه وامثله قام بها
القوات البريه
الروسيات بتدريبات ثم
ظهر انهم هجموا على مواقع
اوكرانيا عليهم بدراسه
الجغرافيا جيدا حتى لا يتعدوا حدودنا ولن
نسمح لهم بان يتعدوا على حدودنا بعد هذا
اليوم اوكرانيا تحارب
طيب انقطع الصوت من المصدر
انقطع الصوت من المصدر لا ادري ان كانت
تسمعنا ولكن سيدنا
الان وكانني فهمت منك بانه قد تكون هناك
عمليات حربيه من الجانب
بلا روسيه ضد اوكرانيا وهو الامر الذي
تضعه كيا في حسبانها كما فهمت انت تقولين
هذه التدريبات حرب وليست مجرد همم تدريبات
وقد يقومون بعمل معين من الحدود
البلاريثيه
تحدثنا عن انهم
ممكن ان يقوموا بمخادعه العالم كله ونحن
نقول هنا انهم بمجرد بغض النظر عفوا عن
اعمالهم هناك نحن ممكن ان نتوقع اي عمل
عدواني من طرفهم ونحن مستعدين لهذا ونحن
مستعدين لاي تطورات على ارض المعركه فاذا
قاموا باي هجمات نحن نعلم كيف ندافع عن
حدودنا ونعلم كيف نصد ايه هجمات ولن نسمح
لهم بعد اليوم ان يخطئ خطوه على اراضينا
سواء كان من اراضي روسيا او مواقع روسيه
باسمي قياده العمليات الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك
الان ننتقل المشاهدين الى ليبيا حيث افاده
مصدر للجزيره بوصول مدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه سي اي اي
ويليامبرز الى مقر رئاسه الوزراء في
العاصمه طرابلس وفق المصادر سيلتقي بارز
رئيس حكومه الوحدات الوطنيه عبد الحميد
البيدر واتوقعت مصادر الجزيره ان يلتقي
بنز لواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر في مقره
بمدينه بن غازي شرقي ليبيا
تبدا ليبيا العام الجديد في ختم تحركات
دبلوماسيه المكثفه وتستقبل طرابلس مديره
وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه السياعي وليم
غاز يبدو التحرك الامريكي لافتا لان الامر
لا يتعلق بوازير خارجيه او وزير دفاع
التقدرت رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد
الحميد بيبا بحضور وزيره الخارجيه نجلاء
المنقوش ولا اخبار عن ترتيب لقاء مع حكومه
المكلفه من مجلس النواب في المقابل يتوقع
ان يلتقي بيرز اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
في مقره بمدينه بن غازي شرقيه ليبيا تاتي
زياره البرنس في سياق ما يبدو انها عوده
الاهتمام الامريكي بالازمه الليبيه فمنذو
اصولها الى السلطه ابدت اداره الرئيس جو
بايدن اهتماما متزايدا بهذه الازمه في
الثامن والعشرين من يناير 2011 طلبت من
روسيا وتركيا سحب قوته من ليبيا وبرز هذا
الاهتمام اكثر بتعيين نولان سفيرا مبعوث
خاصه للرئيس الامريكي في مايو 2021
واظهرت انشطه النور لاند في ليبيا ان
ازمتها اصبحت من اولويات السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان خرط النار في الاتصالات
الجاريه من اجل ازاله العقبات امام تنظيم
الانتخابات طال انتظارها والى جانب هذا
الاهتمام الدبلوماسي ترعى قياده القوات
الامريكيه في افريقيا افريقيا مباحثات
اللجنه العسكري خمسه زائد خمسه ياتي هذا
الاهتمام الامريكي وليبيا في عهد اداره
بادن بعد فطور واضح شهده عهد الرئيس
السابق دون ترامب الذي كان يعتقد ان
الازمه الليبيه ازمه الاوروبيه وليست ازمه
امريكيه
وتميزتا المواقف الامريكيه في عهده
بالتناقض احيانا فعندما شن اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر هجومه على طرابلس في
ابريل عام 2019 اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه
رفضها بالهجوم اما ترامب فقد اتصل بحفطر
وناداه بالمشير وهناء بجهوده ووصفه
بمكافحه الارهاب تغير الوضع الان واصبحت
واشنطن منخرطه بقوه في جهود حل الازمه
الليبيه تفعل ذلك وهي تعرف الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه والاقتصاديه لليبيا وفي
الخلف ينشغالها بالنفوذ الروسي والصيني
المتزايد في المنطقه
مدير مركز بيان للدراسات السياسيه في
ليبيا مرحبا بك سيد نزار برايك ماذا جاء
يفعل وليامبرز في طرابلس
ما اظن ان هذه الزياره تاتي في زياره في
اطار امني
متابع بعض الملفات على راسها طبعا القبض
على
تسليم السيد ابو عجيل المريمي يعني المتهم
في قضايا في قضيه لوكربي وتفجير لوكربي
وان هذه القضيه قد فتحت واصبحت يعني قيد
التحقيق في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اظن ان قد يكون هناك بعض المعلومات التي
سربت
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالاضافه الى
ملفات امنيه اخرى الان اظن ان الاطار
العام في هذه الزياره هو قضيه بوعجال
المريمي وقضايا امنيه اخرى قد تكون يعني
بعض الشخصيات التي ذكرت اثناء التحقيقات
يراد استجوا بعض المسجونين في السجون في
طرابلس همم بعض الشبكات اللي هي ممكن اصبح
التدريب معلومات كافيه عليها طبعا في اطار
تعزيز هذا التعاون لكن هو اظن المساله
كلها في الامن وليس لها يعني البرد
السياسي الكبير يعني
ماذا عن زياره بنغازي المرتقبه ولقائه همم
حفتر
هذا الامر طبيعي يعني بمعنى
التعاون الامني بين ليبيا او بين الحكومات
المتعاقبه في ليبيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ليس جديدا يعني تعاونوا من قبل
مع وزير الداخليه
ايام دونالد ترامب كان في تعاون مع خليفه
حفتر ومحاوله وجود بعض المعلومات حينما
كان يسوق نفسه انه يقاتل الارهاب همم كل
القضايا المتعلقه
بالتهريب بالهجره غير النظاميه همم بقضايا
همم يعني القضايا المتعلقه بالمخدرات لا
تنسى ان هذه الليبي اصبحت يعني همم شبكه
كبيره جدا من المخدرات والمؤثرات العقليه
تنتقل عبر ليبيا وهمم يعني هناك تقرير
دوليه كبيره في ذلك فين هناك همم يعني
اصبحت ليبيا كانها ما اقوى بكثير من
القضايا الشائكه الامنيا هذا هو السبب
اللي يعني يعني الامر مفصول تماما عن
الصراع السياسي في ليبيا نعم يعني هذه هذه
النقطه التي اود ان ات اليها تقول انه همم
اطار امني مفصول كليا عن ال ااه الواقع
السياسي او الازمه السياسيه في ال- في
البلاد ولكن هل يمكن ان تستثمر في اطار
سياسيين من همم قبل الاطراف الليبيه خصوصا
انه يعتبر اهتمام ربما لم نشهده في عهد
الرئيس ترامب مثلا
جانب الامريكي يتعامل مع الملفات الامنيه
الملف ملف ويحال اني احاول ان يحل هذه
القضايا بينما الجانب السي اللي بيحاول ان
يظهر بان هذا اهتمام امريكي لهذا الطرف
يعني عبد الحميد طيبه يريد ان يظهر انه
الحكومه المحترم بها همم خليفه هفتر يريد
ان يظهر انه لاعب دولي والكل يستقبله لكن
ال- ال- العقليه الامريكيه تتعامل ان هذا
ملف يرد حالا مثل المعلومات عن قضيه لا
يمكن ان تقف هذه المعلومات ووجود اقسام
سياسي في ليبيا امام الوصول الى هذه
المعلومات يعني في كل المراحل اللي مرت
بها ليبيا كان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قبضت على
احد المطلوبين في قضايا الارهاب من بعد
مقتل السفير الامريكي كان هناك اتفاق مع
المؤتمر الوطني لتسليم بعض المطلوبين همم
اثناء الحرب على طرابلس كان هناك تعاون مع
فتحي بشار وذكر بالاسماء وانه كان في هناك
تعاون امني فهو الامر ليس بجديد لكن ما
الذي يجعل هذا الامر جديد هو الاستخدام
السياسي للاطراف السياسيه اللي تصوير هذه
الامور على ان اعتراف امريكي معنا الموقف
السياسي الامريكي واضح في كل الملفات
الليبيه وهي قادره على الوصول لكل الاطراف
السياسيه هذا هو الامر يعني ببساطه ان
امريكا تتعامل معهم ملفات الامنيه لقضايا
قد تكون ملحه في في الداخل الامريكي بينما
طرف السياسي الليبي يحاول ان يلبس هذه
الاشياء الامنيه وليس لها بعث سياسي
بالصوره التي تصورها اطراف السياسيه
في ليبيا حدثنا من اسطنبول شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
قبل قمه يابانيه امريكيه مقرره الجمعه
اعلنت الولايات المتحده واليابان اتفاقهما
على تعزيز التحالف في ملعب فريق لمواجهه
التهديدات في شرق اسيا وعلى راسها الصين
وكانت طوكيو قد دخلت شارع الماضي
القائمه منذ هزيمتها في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ورد على تلك الترتيبات قالت
الخارجيه الصينيه العسكريه بين واشنطن و
طوكيو يجب ان لا يضر بمصالحه طرف ثالث
بين اليابان والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مسافه اكثر من 10,000 كيلو متر لكن البعد
الجغرافي لا يعيق باي حال تحالفهم
العسكريه والسياسيه الوثيقه القائمه منذ
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه تحالف تدفعه
التوترات الراهنه في شرق اسيا والحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الى افاق جديده تنزع
عنه كل القيود والمحاذير فاجتماع واشنطن
بين وزراء البلدين للخارجيه والدفاع تمخض
عن توسيع الماده الخامسه من المعاهده
الدفاعيه الثنائيه وتغطيا رد المشتركه على
اي هجوم عبر الفضاء ردا على تزايد القدرات
الصينيه عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه
اما تهديدات كوريا الشماليه فقابلها تاكيد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي استعداد بلاده
لاستخدام السلاح النووي لحمايه اليابان
تتخوف اليابان ومعها الولايات المتحده مما
تسميانه التحدي الصينيه المتناميه في
المنطقه عبر استعراض بجين قوتها العسكريه
وترهيب الجيران وهي مخاوف تفاقمها ايضا
التطورات في شبه الجزيره الكوريه حيث
تتدهور اكثر فاكثر العلاقات بين الكوريتين
وتتساقط مزيدا من صواريخ بيونج في بحر
اليابان
التحالف الياباني الامريكي الذي يدشن حقبه
جديده من المنافسه الاستراتيجيه مع بيجين
سبقته الشهر الماضي ترتيبات الاستثنائيه
في طوكيو التي اقرت مراجعه جذريه لعقيدتها
الدفاعيه نصت بالاساس على زياده ضخمه في
الميزانيه العسكريه
ثلاث سنوات الخمس المقبله وتعزيز قدره
البلاد على الردع والرد على اي هجوم
صاروخي بما في ذلك استهدف مصدر اطلاقها
وذلك تحول هائل في بلد يمنعه دستوره من
تشكيل جيش حقيقي منذ هزيمته قبل سبعين
عاما كما سمحت تلك المراجعات باعاده
انتشار نحو 50,000 جندينا امريكي يتمركز
اكثر من نصفهم في جزيرتي وكناوه
وتزداد هذه الترتيبات اهميه
تجيء عشيه قمه يابانيه امريكيه حيث يصل
رئيس الوزراء الياباني خلال ساعات الى
واشنطن قادما من كندا وغداه جوله قادته
الى اوروبا تزامنا مع استلام بلاده رئاسه
مجموعه الدول الصناعيه السبع الكبرى للعام
الحالي 2023
لاحقا مشاهدينا وفي فقره المتابعه نسال
ضيف الحصاد عن رسائل جوله رئيس الوزراء
الياباني في عواصم اوروبيه بعد اسابيع من
مراجعه العقيده الدفاعيه اليابانيه
[موسيقى]
عينا ميرجارلاند وزير العدل الامريكي
روبرت هارك مستشاره خاصه لتحقيق في اكتشاف
وثائق سريه في منزل الرئيس الجوبيدن ومكتب
كان يستخدمه حين كان نائبا للرئيس في عهد
اداره باراك اوباما وقال لاند في مؤتمر
صحفينا المستشار الخاص يتم التعود بصلاحيه
التحقيق مع اي شخص او كيان قد يكون انتهك
القانون في هذه القضيه
عصام عصام
او كيان قد انتهك القانون في هذه القضيه
لن يخضع المستشار الخاص للاشراف اليومي من
الوزاره ولكنه سيمتثل اللوائح وساتاكد من
ان السيد هارد يتلقى جميع الموارد التي
يحتاج اليها للقيام بعمله ويؤكد هذا
التعيين للجمهور الالتزام الوزاره
بالاستقلاليه
وقل البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي
جانبيدا يتعاملوا مع الوثائق والمواد
السريه بجديه واوضح بيضا في حديث
للصحافيين انه يتعاون مع المراجعه التي
تجريها وزاره العدل بشان تلك المواد
السريه ونحن نتعاون بشكل كامل مع مراجعه
وزاره العدل وفي اطار تلك العمليه فقد قام
فريق المحامين الخاص بي بمراجعه وثائقه
تعود لعمل كنائب للرئيس وانتهوا من ذلك
مساء امس واكتشفوا عددا محدودا من الوثائق
السريه المخزنه في مكتبي بمنزله وقد تم
ذلك ايضا في مركز
وزاره العدل على الفور وقام فريق المحامين
الخاص بي بالتنسيق لتسليم تلك الوثائق الى
وزاره العدل
الامريكيه السابق مرحبا بك سيد بروس فاير
كما تابعنا الرئيس يعني فعليا هو اعترف
بوجود هذه الوثائق على ماذا سينصب تحقيق
روبرت هارك
ان القانون المرتبط الذي يجعل من غير
القانوني ان يتم نقل اي وثائق سريه بدون
اي سلطه منافسه مناسبه او موافقه بدون
وبدون عاداتها الى المنشاه المرخص بها
القضيه القانونيه هي ما هي النيه التي
كانت لدى السيد بعيد عندما تم نقل هذه
الوثائق السريه ووضعها في مكان غير مرخص
وهو في مكتبه في ذلك في هذه الحاله في
الكراج في منزله كان هنالك محاوله لمعرفه
ما الذي كان يفكر به نعرف ان الوثائق كانت
موجوده هناك في حاجته الشخصيه حيازته
الشخصيه لمده سته سنوات هذا هو اساس
التحقيق طيب كيف تتفاعل هذه القضيه او ما
هو الاثر الذي سوف تتركه على الرئيس بيدن
يعتمد على نفسه
ما يستطيع ان يقوم به اذا اراد ان يعطي
ثقه كامله لدى الشعب الامريكي انه لا يخفي
شيئا هو يريد ان يجب ان يرفع
اربع امتيازات هنالك
ان يتخلى عن هذا الامتياز في مساله
التحقيق في رئيس الحالي وايضا
امتياز انه يخفي التواصل المواصلات
العمليات التواصل بين المسؤولين وايضا
امتياز السريه الذي قد يمنع الحصول او كشف
معلومات معينه حول الوثائق التي قد تكون
سريا للغايه والرابع هو يجب ان يتخلى عن
امتيازه حول مسالتي
وعلى خلاف الرئيس ترامب في همم في تحقيق
هو يجب ان يقول انه
يرضى ان يكون يخضع لاي اسئله قد تطرح عليه
هو يحاول ان يبعد نفسه ويميز نفسه عن
الرئيس ترامب الذي يخضع لتحقيق وفي هذه
الطريقه التي بامكانه ان يتخلى عن هذه
الامتيازات في الوقت الذي نرى فيه ان
الرئيس ترامب يقوم بعكس ذلك شكرا
[موسيقى]
وزير العدل الامريكي السابق شكرا لك
تحركن ياباني
ماذا حدث قبل قمه امريكيه يابانيه مرتقده
في واشنطن غدا قبل ساعات قال وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
في جنوب اليابان واحده للتدخل السريع من
سلاح مشاه البحريه الامريكيه
بحلول العام 2025 والحديث لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي
ستستبدل كتيبه مدفعيه بهذه القوه التي
ستكون اكثر فتكا واكثر قدره على الحركه في
بيئه امنيه متزايده الصعوبه نشير الى انه
ينتشر في اليابان حاليا نحو خمسين الف
جنديا امريكيه يتمركز اكثر من نصفهم في
جزيرتيناوه واشنطن وطوكيو اتفاقتها على ان
معاهده الدفاع المشترك تشمل ايضا الا
هجامات التي تتم عبر الفضاء في خطوه تاتي
في خضم تزايد القدرات الصينيه عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه
تزامنا مع ما جرى في واشنطن وقع رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ونظيره الياباني اتفاقا
يسمح لجيش البلدين بالتخطيط لتدريبات
العسكريه اكثر تعقيدا واوسع نقاط نقاقا
وتنفيذي بها
الاعلان عن تعزيز التحالف الدفاعيه بين
الولايات المتحده واليابان جاء خلال مؤتمر
صحفي لوزراء الخارجيه والدفاع في البلدين
رحبت خلاله واشنطن باستراتيجيه طوكيو
الدفاعيه الجديده
لعقيده الدفاعيه وزادت بشكل كبير من
انفاقها العسكري لمواجهه ما تعتبره
تهديدات من الصين وكوريا
منصت عليه هذه المراجعه زياده الميزانيه
الدفاعيه بالنسبه ضخمه تصل خلال سنوات
الخمس المقبله وتعزيز قدره البلاد على
الرد على اي هجوم صاروخيه يستهدفونها
خطه الانفاق العسكريه التي اعلنتها
اليابان هي الاكبر لها منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بقيمه 320 مليار دولار لشراء
صواريخ قادره على ضرب الصين ولتجهيز
البلاد لاي صراع محتمل وتمثل هذه المراجعه
الدفاعيه نقطه تحول حاسمه بالنسبه لليابان
الذي اقر غداه هزيمتها في نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه يحضر عليها تكوين جيشا
حقيقي
وجوله رئيس الوزراء الياباني الاوروبيه
الامريكيه الشماليه تاتي في ظل تدهور
للعلاقات بين الصين واليابان ثاني وثالث
اكبر اقتصاديين في العالمين تواليه
معنى من روما لورينزو تيرمين وهو الباحث
المتخصص في الشؤون
الاسيويه في مركز الدراسات الجيو السياسيه
وجامعه سبينس
سيد لورينزو
ما هي الرسائل التي
يحملها او تحملها زياره رئيس الوزراء
الياباني الى امريكا
واوروبا في في في خضم همم تغيير العقيده
الدفاعيه الياباني
اليوم هو ربما
اهم تغيير واكبر تغيير في الجيش الياباني
وسياسا الخارجيه اليابانيه وهذا الشيء
الرئيس الوزراء السابق
اقترحه في السنوات السابقه وحاول ان يحصل
على الموافقات عليه بالتالي هو الارث
الاهم لرئيس الوزراء السابق ابي
اه دي بالونشنال
لليابان لكي تكون قوه عسكريه فاعله اييي
هو الامر لا يتعلق فقط بالولايات المتحده
لكنها ابعد من ذلك الامر اتى على عقاب
الصور الاصوات التي تاتي عبر الهادئ وفي
الجانب الاخر من الهادئ من واشنطن وايضا
هنالك ايضا همم
الاخرى مثلا ايطاليا والمملكه المتحده في
التي مثلا حصولها على مقاتلات من
السادس وامور اخرى وهي تقترب ايضا من
الكثير من الفاعلين والقوه في الاخرى في
العالم بالتالي لديها اهداف كبيره
جيد لان الصينيه تمثل التحدي الكبير وهي
تسعى من اجل ان تحتوي الصين هنا همم نقطه
نقطه النقاش ايضا الصين دعت الطرفين
الامريكي واليابانيه الى ان اي تعزيز
للتحالف بينهما يجب ان لا يضر باي طرف
ثالث تعزيز هذا تعاون العسكري بين واشنطن
وتوكيو كيف يمكن ان همم يحدث رد فعل عند
الجانب الصيني
شكرا اساسي الصين دائما تاتي بهذه عقليه
الحرب البارده ان الولايات المتحده تحاول
ان
تبنيه تحالفات وان اليابان تتبع نفس
العقليه
الان لا يجب علينا ان نتوقع ربما اي رد
فعل عسكري لكن اذا ما ربما ساءت الامور
وخرجت عن السيطره ربما سنرى الصين تستخدمه
نفس الادوات التي استخدمتها مثلا
التحالفات الاقتصاديه والعقوبات
الاقتصاديه على المنتجات اليابانيه
والضغوطات الاقتصاديه على الاقتصاد
الياباني هذا امر مارسته الصين خلال 20
سنه الماضيه والصين ستبدا ايضا بهذا بتبدا
القيام بهذه الامور اذا ما تعاقدت الامور
واذا مات صعدت في منطقه
جناح بحر الصين شكرا جزيلا لك من روما
لورينزو ترمين الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
الاسيويه في مركز الدراسات الجيوس
السياسيه وجامعه ساديا
[موسيقى]
سنوات الثمانيه الاخيره كانت الاكثر حرا
علي الاطلاق هذا ما جاء في بيان صادر
اليوم عن المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
التي عزت هذه الظاهره المناخيه لارتفاع
متواصل في تركز الغازات الدفيئه وتراكم
الحر وكان العام الماضي السنه الثامنه على
التوالي التي يكون فيها معدل الحراره
العالميه اعلى بدرجه مئويه على الاقل من
مستويات ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه والمسجله
بين 1850 والف 2900 يذكرون ذلك بطبيعه
الحال بالاحترار المناخي الذي يزداد خطوره
مع فشل الحكومات في الالتزام باتفاقيه
المناخيه عالميه والاخرى وما يتسبب فيه
البشر من انشطه ضاره ينذر بكوارث مناخيه
مع مرور السنوات
الكوكادنا وشكرا لكم على حسن
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]